when we first met dom and company they
were merely street racers
now thanks to years of facing
increasingly high profile villains they
have literally saved the world multiple
times
from forgettable crime lords to
incredible super soldiers here are the
fast and furious villains ranked from
worst to best
after the first movie brian o'connor
went on the run to miami where he
quickly made a name for himself in the
local racing scene
and reconnected with his childhood
friend roman pearce
together they work with the us customs
agency to take down a serious drug
operation
run by a man named carter verone who's
played by cole hauser
and while the villain of too fast too
furious isn't exactly a top tier bad guy
not only is his fake argentinian accent
awful but varone is relatively small
potatoes as far as crime bosses go
sure he's got henchmen and a lot of
property but at the end of the day
he's just a rich miami jerk with a dirty
cop or two in his pocket
throughout the movie his only real
leverage over brian and roman
is that he continues to threaten
undercover agent monica fuentes who's
playing the helpless girlfriend and
putting up with his abuse
in the hopes of a large arrest when the
time comes all it takes is a good car
crash and a bullet to the shoulder to
bring the crime boss down for good
despite the hype brought on by bringing
back the original cast for 2009's fast
and furious
audiences ended up settling for another
subpar villain
phoenix calderon the character is
introduced as arturo braga's number one
henchman
and best drug runner he's established
pretty early on as an antagonist when
it's revealed that he killed letty and
has
every intention of killing brian and dom
what makes him one of the lower entries
on this
list is that he fails at literally every
job he has in the movie
first of all it's revealed in fast and
furious 6 that after running letty off
the road and having her at barrow's end
he decides to get fancy and shoot the
gas tank rather than execute her
outright
she lives later in the fourth movie he's
tasked with killing the people who
helped him run drugs under the u.s and
mexico border that team
includes brian and dom surprised he
fails at that too
after a climactic chase through
underground tunnels he does manage to
wipe o'connor's car
and is about to execute him when you
guessed it
he fails dom crashes into him ending his
reign of criminal mediocrity for good
fast and furious tokyo drift is a
strange installment in the franchise
in addition to being the lowest grossing
film of the series it's the single
biggest headache for the timeline of the
fast and furious movies thanks to the
death of han solo
who appears in the next three movies on
top of all that
when it comes to villains it's got one
of the lower rungs on the totem pole
with takashi
the self-proclaimed drift king of tokyo
when young hot shot sean boswell makes
his way to the city looking to break
into the racing scene
he gets a face full of humiliation from
takashi before finding himself entangled
in a web that includes the villain's
yakuza boss uncle
in the end the duo agreed to a drift
race with the loser being forced out of
tokyo for good
if that feels a little low stakes for a
franchise that includes our heroes
running away from a nuclear submarine
that's because it is at the end of the
day takashi is just a rich kid with
great family connections and some
driving acumen
reyes has the distinguished honor of
being one of the many villains in fast
five
a film that marks the franchise's
departure from the realm of dated street
racing movies and
into the realm of the stunt-based action
genre
reyes is another generic south american
crime boss who orders other people to do
his bidding and of course
fails to do anything to scare dom's team
granted he's the reason that the
disjointed characters from the four
previous movies are forced to get
together in one setting but reyes
himself
is not a fighter a driver or a
particularly clever person
in fact most of the movie is spent
seeing dom and his gang straight up
threatening him just so they are able to
more easily steal his stockpile of cash
while actors or keem de almeida does a
great job portraying the crime boss once
the chips are down and there are no more
people
or dirty cops for him to order around
he's a relatively toothless being who
crumbles like a jenga tower when he's
finally faced with the full brunt of the
team
kiet played perfectly by tony jaw in
fast and furious 7
is by far one of the more interesting
antagonists of the franchise
another actor who deserves a lot of
credit is the late paul walker who
clearly worked hard on his stage combat
training in order to look every bit the
match for the incomparable jaw in the
movie
the character is first introduced when
dom's team is intercepting the convoy
carrying ramsay as a prisoner
brian manages to get on board the bus
and he and kiet
engage in an advanced martial arts fight
that's only interrupted when the vehicle
falls on its side
kiet manages to lock brian inside as
it's headed off a cliff but our boy
survives
they encounter each other again at the
climax of the movie where they engage in
yet another high-speed fight
this time however brian manages to get a
clever edge over his opponent
and send him down an elevator shaft to
his apparent doom
in a world where dominic toretto is
constantly portrayed as a step ahead of
literally
everyone he comes across it takes a lot
to successfully pull a fast one on him
in the team
however riley hicks manages to do just
that in a shocking twist that takes
place in fast and furious 6. when the
movie opens
dss agent lucas hobbs is hot on the
trail of owen shaw
however he knows that he needs to bring
dom's team in to successfully apprehend
him
things immediately go south and it
becomes clear that shaw wasn't only
prepared for hobbes and toretto's plan
he was actually expecting it it turns
out that agent hicks
who was a top performer in the dss was
working with shaw the whole time
not only that but the two seem to be
romantically involved as well
which comes as a surprise to letty who
kinda has a thing with shaw herself it
seems
that's why it's not surprising that when
letty and riley encounter each other in
the field
they have one of the better fist fights
of the franchise helped in large part by
the fact that actress gina carano is a
former real life woman's mma fighter
although she meets her in later in the
movie she leaves a distinct mark on the
franchise by helping shaw prepare for a
new class of hero
by staying a step ahead of them for the
better part of the sixth installment in
the franchise
in the hierarchy of threats to dominic
tiretto and his gang
johnny tran is by far the lowest on the
list however he ranks higher than some
villains
in part because he has the distinguished
honor of being the first
fast and furious antagonist tran is the
leader of a gang in los angeles that
deals in high-end electronics for cars
he and dom previously had a relationship
but they agreed to a territory truce
after
dom slept with trans sister as a result
each feared the other while in their
respective territory
however while dom just wanted to race
cars and pull off the occasional dvd
heist
tran had an ever-growing operation that
got the attention of the fbi
unfortunately he crossed the wrong team
at race wars when dom's friend jesse
raced him for pink slips jesse runs
after losing the race
and tran goes off on dom on neutral
territory
inviting a vicious beating upon his face
tran responds by showing up to toretto's
house and murdering jesse
and taking a shot at not only dom but
his sister mia as well
the ensuing chase results in trans death
and solidifies the tense relationship
between dom and brian forever
in short no tran isn't one of the worst
threats that toretto has faced however
when they did cross paths
they were equals and his death put dom
and brian on an entirely new criminal
level
arturo braga has the rare distinction of
being the only villain in the movies so
far
to return and not be considered an
active member of the good guys team
he's introduced in fast and furious as a
longtime heroine smuggler whose cartel
in mexico
has expanded well into los angeles he's
first seen by brian and dom
when the duo are forced to race each
other in order to gain entry
onto his team of drivers he's the man
that pulls phoenix calderon's strings
and he's therefore responsible for all
the hurt that letty's apparent death
causes
especially me however his reach extends
further than that
while he's not the strongest or most
talented villain he's by far the largest
crime boss that the gang had come up
against at that time
his operation is far-reaching driving
alone can't stop him and it forces the
good guys to join forces with the law in
order to take him down
in short braga may not be the most
captivating villain but he's an
important chess piece on the board in
terms of raising the stakes
and making sure these characters don't
stay battling street level tough guys
forever
while decade shaw was far and away the
main villain of furious 7
is actually mosai's akande that causes
the team so much grief in the film
born in nigeria zakhande is a mercenary
and warlord who's determined to bring
his little private army into the
forefront of world dominance through use
of the god's eye
a device that allows the user to hack
and use any piece of technology in a
given area hoping to capture this
terrifying tech
zakhande kidnaps ramsay in an attempt to
force her to give him the device
worse still he almost kills tereto when
our hero tries to rescue the computer
hacker
forcing dom to literally drive off a
cliff rather than face the slew of
bullets shikande plans to send his way
the character becomes a further thorn in
the team side when he allies himself
with deckard after realizing that they
have a shared interest in stopping dom's
team
however he makes the grave tactical
error of turning on deckard once he's
outlived his usefulness during their
climactic battle in los angeles
once zakhande has the god's eye and
control over it he decides to try and
kill both deckard and dom which
obviously doesn't work out in his favor
while he may not have had a ton of
screen time he looms large over the
seventh movie
the fast and the furious movies have a
lot of unnamed or downright useless
henchmen
characters standing out amongst these
nobodies with ease
connor rhodes is perhaps the most
influential sidekick in the entire
franchise
he's incredibly loyal to the villainous
cipher he's one of the men responsible
for blackmailing toretto by kidnapping
elena
and he's even the trigger man when the
time comes to execute her
just to prove a point to dom not only is
actor christopher hirvu a physical match
for the ever imposing vin diesel
but his character proves a proper foil
for him in a movie where the lines of
good and evil are blurred
while dom is a reluctant participant in
cipher's villainy
kana approaches his often heinous tasks
with glee he even attempts to kill luddy
more than once in the movie
finally sparking dom's rage
unfortunately once his blackmail
leverage over dom goes out the window
he's no
match for an infuriated good guy and he
gets his neck snapped right on the hood
of dom's car
after squaring off against mma fighter
gina carano
in fast and furious 6 michelle rodriguez
letty got a sort of title shot in
furious 7
against none other than ufc superstar
ronda rousey
who played abu dhabi based bodyguard
kara when letty has to infiltrate her
princess penthouse she's spotted by the
head of security the aforementioned kara
realizing something is up kara pursues
letty to an off-limits area of the party
and has three female guards attack her
once the three guards are dispatched
it's a one-on-one fight between letty
and kara that's one of the more vicious
and brutal in the franchise
the fight ends in a bit of a draw with
the girls tumbling over a banister onto
a dj setup where letty is able to make a
quick escape from the party
unfortunately that's all of the
character that fans get from the movie
but the fight scene itself made up a lot
of the marketing for the seventh
installment in the franchise
it was so intensive that rodriguez later
admitted to actually sustaining injuries
while filming
after years of increasingly scary
villains putting the team in
increasingly intense situations
the toretto family finds their way to
international acclaim when they are
asked by the american government to help
bust a team of similarly trained thieves
with a penchant for quote
vehicular warfare the antagonists are
led by owen shaw
a former sas operative who spent the
last few years as a mercenary
he's revealed to have been the one
pulling arturo braga's strings
showing him how to think of his
operation more globally than locally
in many ways owen represents everything
that dominic and his crew have been
preparing for their whole lives
his team is essentially a mirror version
of dom's and his ultimate goal
is to create something that could
literally destroy the world
owen hits them not only on a personal
level but a professional one as well
making him far and away their toughest
villain at this point in the series
he would likely be higher on the list if
he didn't return in the fate of the
furious
as an ally to the very man who put him
in a coma
if owen shaw deserves top marks for
having braga in his pocket
cipher edges him out on the list because
she actually had owen in hers
played by the inimitable charlize theron
she's revealed in the fate of the
furious as an expert hacker who
successfully managed to convince the
world that she's not actually a person
but a hacking collective
she uses her skills to move both people
and governments around like chess pieces
in order to secure herself some massive
power such as the use of the god's eye
and a nightshade device do you all enjoy
that
next generation concussion grenade it
scrambles your senses
in addition similar to owen she manages
to hit dominic
really close to home by kidnapping his
ex-girlfriend
alina nives and the son he didn't know
they had together
however unlike shaw who failed to kill
both letty and mia
cipher successfully executed selena just
to prove a point
unlike many of the other villains that
dared across toretto's path
she manages to escape without suffering
serious bodily harm
and as the series is still ongoing it
looks like cipher is set to pose even
more problems for our heroes going
forward
a lot of people on this list have been
given bad marks for joining up with dom
and his crew
after spending an entire movie trying to
end their lives in deeply personal ways
while normally it's the mark of a bad
villain to become a somewhat morally
questionable good guy in the end it
works for deckard shaw
thanks to the incomparable charm of
jason statham decade is first introduced
at the end of fast and furious 6
when it's revealed that the accident
that killed han was no accident at all
it was a targeted hit designed to place
a shot across the bow of dom's family
for what they did to shaw's little
brother owen
he then spins furious 7 on a relentless
mission to finally give dom a run for
his money as the film's core villain
unfortunately he's defeated in a car
park fist fight by dom
it's revealed in subsequent movies
though that shaw's reputation as a
murderer who betrayed his country was a
false narrative created by his enemies
although he's quite the badass he has a
code that he lives by
prior to joining up as a reluctant ally
in the fate of the furious he was a
mercenary for hayer who only took
missions that would allow him to sleep
at night in other words he's a
complicated villain in a franchise
filled with some typical point-and-click
baddies
although his recruitment in dom's family
is a little unorthodox
the films go out of their way to explain
that he belongs and his charisma led to
the first spin-off movie hobbs and shaw
that left very few fans complaining
prior to the spin-off hobbs and shaw
precious little was known about deckard
other than he was a well-trained
mercenary who you really didn't want to
cross
although his change from villain to hero
is pretty much completed in the fate of
the furious
his involvement with a man named brixton
law solidified his role as a good guy
brixton was an mi6 alongside shaw early
on in their respective careers
however deckard didn't share brixton's
apathy for human life and therefore put
a bullet in his head
what he didn't know was that brixton
survived the assassination attempt
and was given mechanical and biological
enhancements by a nefarious
organization known as etion that turned
him into an
actual super soldier all the other
additions to this list
are villains in their own right but
brixton's status as a literal super
villain
makes him far and away the worst threat
anyone involved with the team has
ever had to encounter even his
motivations stand head and shoulders
above his competition
owen shaw for example wanted to unleash
a weapon on the world
but he did it for personal gain brixton
however has fully bought into etion's
company line about enhancing the human
race
and making people evolve into the next
stage of existence
he even gets particularly cross with
hattie shaw when she suggests that he's
merely a prophet based killer
in short for a franchise that got its
start with street level villains causing
the occasional drive-by over turf wars
an avengers level super villain is hard
to compete with
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the fast and the furious franchise are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one